Hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video. Today we're going to be doing
another farming uh money maker video.
This one is uh kind of interesting. I
found three different ways you can make
money farming. Now, herb runs are going
to be your go-to uh bread and butter uh
for when you're farming, but there are
some other ways that are actually kind
of fun, and you can add on to your farm
runs or just mix it up if you're getting
a little bored. And yeah, let's get into
it. So, the first way to make uh some
easy money farming beyond using herb
runs uh is going to be farming cactuses.
Now, the cactus spines are worth about
eight or ninek each, sometimes up to
10k, and um you can farm one spine, I
believe, every 80 minutes. Uh it doesn't
sound like a lot, but is extremely easy
to get to. Uh you only need to plant the
one seed. After that, you'll just come
back and pick the spines. Uh you will
need 55 farming to start doing this. Uh
but once you do, it's pretty easy to
incorporate into a farm run. All you
need is a ring of dueling. Getting there
is super easy. No requirements. Just go
to the dual arena. From there, you're
just going to run a little bit south to
where the cactus patch is. This is the
only one in the game, so it's pretty
easy to keep track of. Um I just tag it
in with my herb runs because um it kind
of lines up roughly with when the herbs
are done. Herbs are a little bit
quicker, but uh you don't usually check
exactly on the dot every time. Uh so run
down here. We're going to rake the patch
cuz it needs to be uh plant the cactus.
And uh yeah, it's you're not actually
going to harvest. You're going to
harvest the spines, but you're not going
to remove the cactus. Just going to
plant it once. Once you harvest it,
that's it. You just come back in another
80 minutes to get some more. And I would
recommend using a super compost because
um you only have to plant the the plant
once, so you might as well. So, we'll
come back uh when this has grown, and
we'll show you how it works. All right,
so our cactus has totally grown. It took
a while to grow, but now that it is
fully grown, it will produce a spine
every 25 minutes. Uh so, let's go ahead
and we'll check the health first.
No disease. Perfect. And let's pick
those cactus spines off of there.
One,
two, three, and looks like 22k. So,
we'll just head back to GE and see what
we can sell it for. All right. So, that
literally took a minute to go harvest
that. It's really close. And let's just
see if we can dump it for that price.
Perfect. 22k doesn't seem like a lot,
but it's extremely easy. Only a minute
of work, and you can tag it into all
your farm runs. So, next up, uh what
we're going to be farming are fruit
trees. Now, this can be done pretty
profitably with two different items,
both papaya trees and uh palm trees,
which are for coconuts. I would
recommend using coconuts, but my farming
level actually isn't that high yet. So,
we're going to just show you with palm
trees. Uh but I believe coconuts are
almost always more profitable. Uh so,
what you have to do is just buy some of
these saplings. So, we have four uh
papaya saplings, and then we're just
going to do a normal fruit tree run, and
I will come show you quickly in case you
don't actually know where to go of the
four locations that are easy to get to.
There is a fifth one in Letia, uh, but I
don't have that unlocked yet. So, the
Tome Stronghold is the easiest. So,
you're just going to take the, uh,
spirit tree here, then run to the east a
little bit. Here's the first patch.
Again, recommend using super compost
because you only have to grow the tree
once. After that, you're just going to
come back and harvest it. Uh, so there
we go. Planted the first sapling. From
here, you're going to run to the uh,
other spirit tree in the Trenome uh,
sorry, the tree village. And uh I would
recommend just going right from the
Trinome stronghold. From there, you're
just going to run a little bit to the
west. And then you're going to take uh
the shortcut out and uh follow uh what's
his name again? The little gnome out.
He'll follow up instantly. Teleport you
outside of the maze. Uh Elcoy. Elcoy.
And uh from there, you're just going to
run a little bit south and the other
patch should just be right there. All
right. And there's our second sapling
planted. Now, from here, the other patch
is in Catherby, which is pretty far
away. Uh, the closest place I can get to
it from is Camelot. And from here, you
just have to run all the way down to the
bottom right corner and the the other
patch will be there. All right, we're in
Catherby now. And I'm kind of feeling
this one's a little debatable. You might
want to omit this one just because it's
such a long run distance compared to the
other ones. Um, it's kind of up to you.
It took me about a minute and a half to
get here from my nearest teleport. And
the other places were like pretty much
right there. Anyway, if you want to
incorporate this one, it's way down
here, just to the southeast of Catherby.
And uh yeah, we'll plant this and then
go to the last patch. Okay, and the last
patch is on uh Crja. It's in Brim Haven.
Uh so I find the easiest way for me is
to just teleport to our dune and then
from here just run a little bit to the
southeast and then take the boat over.
Uh which pops you up pretty close to the
actual farming location. Um you could
use a glory if you don't have access to
the Ardune teleport and they're probably
a closer way beyond that. Uh, but this
is the easiest way for me. And the quest
to unlock this teleport really isn't
that hard. Uh, once you're here, just
get off the gang plank and then run a
little bit to the south and the farming
patch is right there. Uh, I'm thinking I
would recommend just those three. I
would omit the one in Catherby just
because it's so far to get to. These
ones are much closer and um the distance
might not be worth it. Anyway, we'll
come back when the trees have grown and
we'll see how much we actually get from
the four patches. All right, we've left
the papayas in overnight, so hopefully
none of them died. Um, but it's not a
huge deal if they do. Uh, because you
just need to try again and eventually
you'll get all your trees to be healthy.
And the first papaya looks like it is
good. So, we'll go ahead and uh just
pick that or check it first. 6k XP. Wow,
I forgot about that. And, uh, pick the
fruit. And we can see that each papaya
fruit is uh not worth that much, but
it's uh 1.7k. This is going to work a
bit better with coconuts. Another uh
thing worth noting is the tool
leprechaun can note the papayas for you.
So just use it on him if you're running
out of room. And we got 12 so far. Uh
now just keep in mind that papayas used
to be worth 1k and they might be worth
that much again. So it's I wouldn't
recommend this one as much right now uh
because of the current prices, but in
general I mean if that was 1k that'd be
12k. We get about 24k in total. With
coconuts it's going to be about 500
each. Uh so it's definitely worth doing.
Uh, but I probably wouldn't do papayas.
And our third tree is all good. Uh, it
looks like you get six papayas from each
tree. And we'll move on to our very last
tree. Oh, almost had four for four. All
right, so we got 24 papayas. Uh, only
took about a couple minutes to do this.
Now, this method has worked a lot better
in the past when they were worth 1k
each. Right now, it's about a third of
the profit. So, just keep this in mind
for later when the prices do rise back
up. Uh, cuz right now, I wouldn't really
recommend it. It's not really that time
efficient. But right now, the cactus
spine would be much more efficient. Now,
for the third method, what I'm going to
be showing you is how to profit from
making saplings. Now, there's a ton of
different saplings you can pick from.
You can do regular tree saplings or
fruit tree saplings. Uh, for this video,
I'm going to be doing papaya saplings.
Um, they're pretty easy to do. Uh, the
seeds buy pretty quickly, so that's why
I chose the papaya trees. Um, I've done
it with maple seeds. Uh, and you can do
it with U or magic, but I don't quite
have the farming level for that. Uh, so
right now I'm getting about a 1.7K
margin on each sapling we are going to
make. Uh, giving us about 350K in profit
off of, uh, doing 200 seeds, which is
the buying limit. So, we're going to put
an offer in for 8731. On top of that, we
do need to buy some filled plant pots,
uh, which are extremely cheap, and
you're going to need some watering cans.
So, put an offer in the GE for watering
cans. Uh, you can reuse those, so it
won't be very expensive. And yeah, we'll
come back when the uh seeds have bought.
All right, we're back and uh we have
bought all the pie tree seeds. Uh really
only took about 45 minutes maybe. Uh so
we bought them all for 8735 all but one
uh cuz we hit the limit of course. Uh
pull out all the filled planter pots.
Okay, so now that we have all the seeds
bought, uh it takes two steps to get the
saplings created. First we have to put
them into the pots. After that we have
to uh water them. So, the easiest uh way
is just withdrawn inventory filled pots
first. Fill up all the pots. Uh do all
of them and then water them afterwards.
So, it's pretty easy. Just pop the seeds
in the
pot. And um just like that, easy. And uh
we'll come back when they're all been
potted and then we'll go add the water
to them. Okay, so we just finished up
adding all the seeds to the pots. There
we go. All 199 have been added to the
pots. Really didn't take too long. Uh
next up, we just need to water them. So,
take out the uh papaya seedlings or
saplings, sorry, and a watering can. Uh,
now you have to buy these unfilled on
the Grand Exchange. Uh, from there, you
can just fill them at any water source.
It's pretty easy. And, uh, same thing,
just add water to them. And, uh, we just
have to do all 200 of them. Again, once
they've been watered, uh, you do have to
wait about 5 minutes for them to become
mature saplings, fully ready, and able
to be sold on the Grand Exchange. Uh so
we'll come back then uh once they've uh
all been watered and are ready to sell.
All right guys, so uh we're back and uh
we have 199 papaya saplings in our bank.
Uh we watered them all. Then about
within 5 minutes they all turned into
saplings. Uh so we're going to withdraw
all those. Go to grand exchange and
we'll just go buy another one just to
double check what the margin is going to
be. Papaya
saplings and oh right I forgot. Uh we
hit the buying limit. I guess they do
share a buying limit. Or maybe they're
just more expensive than that. Try one
more time. Okay, no, we're good. Bought
them for 11k, so that's actually a bit
higher than it was before. So, we'll pop
them in for
$1099. Good. So, we'll come back and uh
hopefully these will all sell for that
price. So, all these saplings uh sold
and let's see how much profit we got
from all of that. So, we sold them for
2.2 mil and uh yeah, it's going to give
us about 450k in profit. uh which is
really good. This is by far the most
profitable way to make farming or make
money farming, sorry. And uh yeah, I'm
really happy with how that turned out.
You can do it with a bunch of different
seed or saplings. Uh all the tree
saplings, all the fruit tree saplings uh
will all work sometimes. Just depends on
your farming level and what the margins
happen to be. All right, guys. That
about wraps us up for today. I hope you
enjoyed the video and maybe learned a
couple things about farming. And I will
see you guys next time.
[Music]